Good afternoon.
I'm Amina Zubaida from University of British Columbia in Vancouver,
Canada. For those of us who don't know, it is just north of here.
I hope that everyone is enjoying this spectacular
meeting. It has been my
distinct honor
to serve as the chair of this year's
selection committee for the 2026 AACR Team
Science Award. It's established in
2007 by the AACR and supported by
Lilly since its inception. The AACR Team Science
Award recognize outstanding interdisciplinary research
team whose innovation and meritorious science has
significantly advanced or hold great promise to
advance our fundamental understanding of cancer.
The award also honors team that have successfully
applied existing knowledge to improve the detection,
diagnosis, or prevention, or
treatment of cancer. The 2026
AACR Team Science Award is presented to the Broad
Institute Cancer Dependency Map, or a DeepMap Team.
The DeepMap Team is a remarkable consortium of
academic scientists, data scientists, and healthcare
professional who pioneered systematic mapping of
genetic dependency across cancer cells.
Through their collective effort, they have created
a comprehensive, publicly accessible resources that
identify genes and pathways essential for tumor
survival.
The work has reshaped our understanding of cancer
biology and opened new avenue of the discovery
of precision therapies.
The Cancer Dependency Map
team recognized the limitation of studying single
gene or pathway in isolation.
They moved beyond those constraint by launching
large-scale effort to map cancer
dependence across diverse tumor type.
The DeepMap integrates CRISPRase essentiality
screen and drug sensitivity data with genomic,
epigenomic, metabolomic, and proteomic
characterization across more than 1,000 cancer cell
line.
By combining functional genomics, pharmacologic profiling, and
multi-omics data at unprecedented scale,
the DeepMap team has uncovered lineage and
genotypic-specific cancer vulnerability.
These include clinical actionable synthetic lethal
dependencies such as VRN for microsatellite instability
cancers, and PRMT5 dependency in
cancer harboring MTAP
deficiencies.
The transformative data set generated by the team now
serves as a fundamental global resources, accessed
daily by cancer researchers across disciplines.
The winning team, led by Dr. Francesca Vazquez.
Additional team members include Jesse Bowen,
Katrina Campbell,
Glen Cawley,
Joshua Dempster,
Levi Garraway,
Bill Han,
Todd Goelz,
James McFarland, Philip Montgomery,
David Root, Jennifer Roth, Bill Sellers,
Monye Tang,
Avi Cherniack, and Barbara Wier. Together,
this team has transformed the discovery and the
prioritization of therapeutic targets,
establishing DeepMap as a critical engine for cancer
research and drug development worldwide.
Today, we will hear from Dr. Francesca Vazquez
and Dr. Bill Sellers, who will share
insight into how Cancer Dependency Map was built,
and how this powerful resources is being used
to advance drug discovery and inform clinical trial.
On behalf of AACR and 2026
Award Selection Committee, I extend out my
warmest congratulations to the DeepMap team.
It is now my pleasure
to welcome Dr. Francesca Vazquez to begin today the session.
Thank you.
Thanks, Amina, for the nice introduction, and thanks
to the whole DeepMap team for letting me represent them
today. So what I want to start, thank you to the
AACR and the selection committee for giving us
this award.
I speak on behalf of the whole team when I say that we're truly honored
that AACR has recognized our work.
Since the beginning, when we only had ideas and
concept and a shared conviction that building a data set
like this was going to be worthwhile, we thought it would matter.
We just didn't know how much. So being here recognized by
AACR in this room with scientists and clinicians,
both for industry and academia, they are working to turn discoveries into
therapies means more than I can express.
And, because this is the community for which we
do build DeepMap. So today, what I would like to
do is use the time to tell you the story on how we got here
and to thank the people that did the
work.These are my
disclosures.
The idea behind DMAP is simple. We use cell line models
of human cancer. We try to represent the diversity,
molecular and genetic diversity of cancer using thousands of
models.
And we do molecular profiling, omics, the
same that one would do with a tumor biopsy.
But because these are cell lines, we can also do drug sensitivity
testing and identify the genes that are required for cell
growth. We can then integrate these two layers of information, so
we can directly link cancer vulnerabilities to the
molecular alterations of the tumors.
So this connection between human cancer through
the models to a drug,
is what DMAP was built for.
Over the past 15 years or so, we have created this resource,
which has been growing over time in both the number of dataset,
the data types, and also the number of cancers that are represented.
The datasets are all in one place and integrated.
We put a lot of effort so all these dataset can talk to each other.
And the data has been used for many use
cases, including probably one of the most important one, to
identify new targets for therapy.
It has also been used to validate and equally important, to
invalidate targets, which
can save a lot of time and resources.
It has used to guide drug discovery programs,
identify dependencies in selected patient populations,
biomarkers of response, and these are large scale datasets,
so we can identify patterns. So DMAP has provide us a systems
view of cancer biology.
So now I'd like to tell you how we got here.
So many things and people had to come together to build DMAP.
First, we needed large collection of cell lines, and we needed them
well-characterized. We needed to find way to find
essential genes to determine which genes were essential in each
of the cell lines. We needed to profile drug sensitivity
profile across hundreds of models.
We needed to build a computational infrastructure.
We were creating large scale dataset. We wanted to integrate.
Many of these datasets were new. Nobody had built them before, so we
needed our methods, and we needed software.
We needed a tool to share and be able to easily explore the
data. But these didn't come together at once, and it wasn't
designed like this. It came together over time.
So I'll tell you a little bit of story.
This took 15 years, so I'm going to try to do it justice.
So very early days, when we were trying to model
cancer, we were doing so by having three or
four well-behaved cell lines that grow really well in the lab.
Now we know cancer is highly heterogeneous.
There's many tumor types, subtypes, molecular features, copy
number changes, et cetera.
Which I'm trying to illustrate here on the left.
So we were trying to model what's on the left, with what's on the right,
which was clearly a mismatch.
So let me take a moment to talk about the NCI60.
NCI60 was this collection of 60 cell lines that the NCI
put together to do drug sensitivity testing, and it
identify differential sensitivities across the cell line.
Although these 60, it seems small, and it was
small, nevertheless, it did provide the first hint that
doing drug sensitivity profiling across different cell
types representing different tumors could identify differential sensitivities.
And in fact, the EGFR inhibitor sensitivity
to EGFR mutant cell lines was discovered using
this panel.
But clearly that was not enough. It was
relatively small. So Bill Sellers and Levi
Garraway decided to change that and to dramatically
expand the number of models. So they set up to do
1,000 models, to collect those models, and then do profiling and drug
sensitivity testing. That was a major undertaking at the
time, and including now, just by collecting those 1,000 models.
But Jordi Barretina and colleagues at the Broad
Institute, as well as Novartis Oncology, did the
work, and this is how the Cancer Cell Line Encyclopedia
was born. It was a transformative project that has been used, I'm
sure many of you know about CCLE, now is part of
that map, and it has been helpful for cancer research,
but also beyond, as well, to select
models for the studies, but also other
things.
Now, around the same time, a technological
breakthrough happened. That is the ability to do
genome scale genetic perturbation screens.
At a time this was using shRNA reagents that were coming
online.
And before that, if we wanted to test if a gene was
essential for cell growth, we needed to knock down that gene with
one shRNA or hopefully a few of them, and then
test if that gene was killing the cells.
And if we wanted to do the whole genome, we will have to repeat this 20,000
times. When genome scale
shRNA screens, in this case, were possible, now we could
test all the genes in the genome at once in one experiment,
where we could determine
if they were required for cell growth very easily or
easier.
So Dave Root Lab and Bill Han and many
other groups made this possible, and it has been
really transformative. In fact, this is how genetic
perturbation screens at scale startedNow,
with this in hand,
Bill Hahn decided to start Project Achilles.
So the Project Achilles, the goal was to
do genetic perturbation screens with shRNA
in at least 100 lines. That was a major undertaking.
Doing genome scale screens was not easy, was not
as easy as doing
an RNA-Seq, for instance. And
the idea here was, if we were to do this, we could, one, compare
genes to each other. We could know which of the genes that we're testing is
better at killing the cells versus others.
And we could also know, importantly, which gene were killing all the cell lines
that were turning to be pan-essential, that would not make them
particularly good drug targets, and which of those
were more selective.
So Jesse Boehm brought the team together,
and
Barbara Wier, here in the room, she was the lead computational
scientist for the project. And Glenn Cowley
made the largest scale screen possible at a
scale that no one could imagine that it could be done.
But shRNA, unfortunately, wasn't as good
as we would've liked it, although we are still using shRNA data, so it's
definitely useful. But nevertheless, a few years later,
Feng Zhan was working on CRISPR, and
we knew the technology was transformative, so we invited Feng to
one of our Achilles meetings. And
after that meeting, we started a transition from RNAi to
CRISPR. We did a pilot screen,
and we did a comparison between
shRNA and CRISPR, and it was clear that
with CRISPR, we could separate better the genes that were essential
versus not essential. This is what I'm showing in this graph, where I'm showing the
distributions, in blue of the
non-essential, in red of the essential.
At the bottom is shRNA, and the top is CRISPR.
You can see how much better separated the distributions are in
CRISPR versus shRNA. So these allow us to identify
significantly more gene dependencies with CRISPR.
Now, as we were building these data sets,
we
realized we needed to start building a computational infrastructure.
We wanted to integrate the data. Many of these data sets were unique.
Nobody had built the large scale shRNA data set before,
and nobody has integrated the data.
So we needed new computational tools. We need a pipeline.
We need a software. So Abhijit Czerniak founded the Cancer
Data Science,
with the purpose of this, building a computational
infrastructure for the map that we can
use to make use of all of this data. And
this team has grown over the years.
It has evolved in parallel as we have been evolving
them up with new data sets and growing.
And Jay McFarlane, after Abhijit, took it
further. He built additional computational methods,
and Katharina Kampert now leads it, bringing her own
vision, and pushing this infrastructure forward.
I would say this team has been my partners in crime for a very long
time, and without them, Demap would not be what
it is today.
Now that we had these pieces together, we had the shRNA
data, the omics data, and the computational infrastructure,
now we could had enough to build the first map.
So this is a publication where the terminology cancer dependency
map first appeared.
And in this manuscript,
we
created the framework to link molecular features of the
tumors to cancer dependencies.
This proved possible. We identify many of the
known oncogene addictions that took years to identify
before this.
For instance,
dependency in KRAS mutant cell lines, BRAF dependency in BRAF mutant cell lines.
We identified most of them if we had
cell lines. And so this paper
proved that the concept was right,
that we could map systematically and link systematically these
dependencies to molecular features.
But there was a lot of work to be done.
Now, until here, we were still missing drug sensitivity.
We had a little bit of data, but we didn't have data at a scale that we
needed. So doing drug sensitivity tested across
many cell lines, never mind across hundreds, I'm sure
you realize that it's very time-consuming, expensive.
You have to thaw each of these lines.
You have to test the drug sensitivity. You have to freeze it back.
And this takes a long time. So to Gallup, and Channing
Woo was working in his lab at the time, invented this
technology, prism. And the idea was that each of the cell
lines could be labeled with a DNA barcode.
Once the cell lines are labeled, they could be pooled together.
So now once they are in pool, you could test their drug sensitivity,
and they convolute the data by identifying the abundance of the
barcode pre and post-treatment. So this was
successful, and they built an assay.
This assay, early days, was not very high throughput.
It was an academic assay. But Jen Roth and her
team over the years have really made this assay
transformative.They have taken this assay and
made it an industry standard, very reproducible, very high
quality data that now hundreds of companies are using
to test their drugs.
But in addition to that, now it does provide us an
opportunity to include drug sensitivity data in
Demap, and we are currently testing all the newer sort of
therapeutics
that have been released in the past few years.
Bill is going to talk a little bit more about this.
Now, the last piece, but equally important, is the Demap portal.
Because we wanted to put all these data set into one place.
We wanted to be able to use them in a very easy way.
So Phil Montgomery, who's a brilliant software engineer,
and who's always behind the scene, and I'm sure he's not going to be happy when
he hears that I'm showing his picture.
But nevertheless, he deserves a lot of credit.
He started Demap in 2019, and he still leads it,
the Demap portal, and he still leads it.
And the portal has again evolved as the Demap data has been evolved.
We added more data sets, which then requires more tool in the portal,
more integration, et cetera. So he and his team have been doing
this.
Now I'm going to take a couple minutes to tell you about some
breakthroughs that are less visible, that are equally
important, but they are behind the scene, but make the visible breakthroughs
possible.
So at a time when we still had the CCLE and the Achilles
teams and two different teams, highly collaborative, but nevertheless,
they were two different teams. Everybody was doing things in more or less their own
way. So we run into the issue, which is we needed to
decide which ID we were going to use for Demap as we were
combining these projects. Computational scientists do
get very attached to their IDs.
So I started
the Demap ID summit. I put everybody into a room and
would not let them leave until they decided which ID we were going to use.
So I'm pleased to tell you that we decided to use the Achilles ID.
I was on team Achilles, so quietly cheering from the background.
And so now if you go to the portal, you see this ACH
and a number. I'm sure many of you, if you use the portal.
So if you ever wonder where the ACH come from, it stands for
Achilles.
Now, as I said, we had to build computational tools over the years
to make sure that this data was
usable. And one of the tools that we built was Chronos.
So I'm going to use that to illustrate how important this is.
So I said that shRNA data is better and
cleaner than CRISPR data, I'm sorry, is better and cleaner than shRNA,
and that's true. However, that doesn't mean that CRISPR doesn't have its own
bias. You have to keep in mind that we're trying to combine screens that
are done in each of the cell lines independently into one data
set. So CRISPR has some off-target effects due
to copy number and amplification, leading to toxicity because it has too
many cuts,
screen quality biases across cell lines, and so on and so on.
So Josh Debcher, computational scientist in CDS,
built Chronos. Chronos models all these biases
and noise to create a score,
what we call the gene effect score, or Chronos gene effect score.
So when you go to the portal, you are using the Chronos gene effect score.
So this is the best score that we can give you that's closer
to the truth of how sensitive a cell line when you
suppress a gene, so that your discoveries can
be validated.
Now, finally, in this section, I'm going to talk about data
releases. I'm going to talk about this a few times, but here what I say
is we have been releasing data on a regular basis every
year since 2018. And releasing data for
Demap is not easy and gets more and more complicated
every year. This is because we keep bringing new more cell lines, new data types,
which means more pipelines, more workflows, more data sets
to be released.
And this is the team that makes the data releases possible.
They work together to make sure that every release works and is
accurate. They fix any bugs along the way.
And what I'm showing here on the left is a real screenshot of
Samantha Stocks, who's working with the team to try and decide
which pipelines we're going to be releasing, which data set, which
ones we need to hold because they are not ready for prime time.
So this is the team that makes it all happen.
But none of this was built alone. Like as any project, we
had many partnerships that were critical for
building Demap, and I'm going to highlight a few.
First one is the
Demap consortium, before it was the Achilles consortium.
So this is a partnership between industry and
academia to build a shared resource that has been
transformative for drug
discovery. And in very early on,
the vision was that if we were able to
build all the data sets together, then they could be integrated rather than any
institution or company doing it on their own, that then they will have one
data set, but they will not be able to combine.
So this was a way to synergize and build all
this in one place. And it has been very successful.
This is what we did. The consortium started with a
small version during Achilles, and then it grew to the Demap
Consortium 1.0, 2.0. We just announced the
DMC 3.0, and we have 22
companies that are joining. Without this partnership,
it would not have been possible to build what we have built with
Demap. So this was really critical that we all
came together and decided that it was important to build
this
resource
in one place.And Kelly Sullivan and China Bits,
our alliance managers, have really built so much trust and
made this consortium
successful.
Now, while we were building
the map in
Cambridge, USA, there was a different map in Cambridge, UK,
that was getting started. This was a completely independent project
started by Matthew Garnett, Francisco Neuro and others at the
Sanger Institute. So they started by doing drug sensitivity
screenings across panels of cell lines, then they brought in
CRISPR. So the concept was very similar.
So we started to collaborate on a change note over the
years, and at some point we decided that it was a good
idea to bring everything under the map
name, so that the community will know that we had the
same framework. So this is what we did, and there is the cancer
dependency map at Sanger. And I'm going to
highlight one particular collaboration, which is
when we got together to compare CRISPR data sets, they
were
doing their CRISPR data set with their protocol, their people
in a different country. And we were doing this here with our protocol in different
people, different country. And what we were pleased to see is that the data
was highly concordant, and this made us
to really trust the data and also made the
community trust the data, and now we published this manuscript.
And now,
the last partnership I'm going to highlight is a very important one and dear to my
heart, which is the Pediatric Cancer Dependency Accelerator.
This is a collaboration between the Dana-Farber Cancer Institute, St.
Jude Children's Hospital, and Broad,
which we started a few years ago. The goal of this partnership
is to accelerate precision cancer
medicine for children using DMAP-like approaches.
Pediatric cancer is rare, so as such, it often tends to
be underrepresented in
large efforts like DMAP. So this initiative
changed that. We have dramatically increased the number of
pediatric cancers now represented in DMAP, and we're continuing to
do so. We are representing cancers that had zero
cell lines before. Many interesting findings are emerging from this
data, so you'll hear more. And children
with cancer deserve all our effort, we would all agree.
So all of us are very committed to this collaboration.
So what did the DMAP make possible?
One of the most important, I think,
aspects of DMAP has been the identification of
new therapeutic targets, and particular synthetic lethal targets.
The ability to link molecular alterations to cancer
vulnerabilities, because this, for the most part, is not possible just
by sequencing genomes. But here now we have both the
expression copy number, the baseline data, but we also have
which genes are required for cell growth.
So we can do link, in real time, those
two data types and find biomarker-driven
therapeutic targets.
The community, all of you, there have been many
discoveries and new interesting targets that are making their
way,
but today I'm going to highlight three of them.
These are the ones that are closer to me, but also many
are familiar to you, and particularly the first two, PRMT5 and
Werners, maybe less so the third one.
So one of the most common cancer
alterations is the chromosomal arm deletion.
These deletions, the cells want to delete the tumor suppressor gene, but there are
many other genes that get co-deleted with it.
Those genes might not be required for cell growth, but nevertheless, they can
create vulnerabilities. So one of those is chromosome
9p21. This is a locus that is very frequently deleted in cancer, one of
the most frequently deleted. And
with the tumor suppressor genes in this region, there are also other genes
that are deleted, and in particular, this gene MTAP.
MTAP is an enzyme that turns methylthioadenosine
into methionine, and if the cells do not have MTAP, then they
accumulate MTA.
So a decade ago or so now, our teams wanted to
identify if there were new dependencies created by
MTAP deletion. So now we had the data to look for
those. So we classified the cell lines into MTAP deleted or
MTAP intact, and they look for dependencies using the shRNA
data that were preferential in MTAP deleted.
And we identified PRMT5. There were three manuscripts
at the same time. They all converged into the same finding, that PRMT5
was a selected dependency in MTAP-deleted
cancers. And this is a very interesting
biology story behind it, but I'm going to
let you read the papers if you're interested.
But I'll say that inhibitors of PRMT5 had reached
clinical trials, so this is very exciting to us.
Now, another very common genetic alteration in cancer is chromosomal
instability. Microsatellite instability is one of
such
instabilities. This is caused by mismatch repair
deficiencyAnd due to that,
DNA replication errors that make the cells accumulate indels.
So we hypothesized that this indel accumulation might lead to new
vulnerabilities. So we took the same approach.
We classified the cell lines into microsatellite stable and unstable,
and now we have both CRISPR and our RNAi data,
so we evaluated this in both, look for preferential
dependencies in microsatellite unstable cell lines.
And here we find the same both with CRISPR and shRNA.
We had similar results.
We found that Werner, which is a DNA helicase,
was
only sensitive, in this case, in MSI
cell lines. In this case, there were also three manuscripts
that were published together. So that's instant
validation of this finding. So there were many
companies that were going to develop inhibitors, and now they have reached
clinical trials or they are being evaluated.
In my third and last example, so after
we had more CRISPR data, so when we did the
MMTAP analysis, we only had shRNA data.
Now we had a lot more CRISPR data, a lot more cell lines.
So we revisited the 9p21 deletion,
and we did the same analysis here. We classified the cell lines by
9p deletion or intact, and again, look for dependencies.
And reassuringly, we did find BRMT5,
but we also find this other gene, Pelo, together with HBS1L,
which form a complex.
And then again, here now we had two publications coming
out at the same time, and again, instant sort of validation of
the finding.
This one was particularly interesting because not only
chromosome 1921 deletion, but we saw that some cell
lines were still sensitive. They did not have the deletion.
So we investigated that, and we found that microsatellite instability
was also leading to Pelo dependency, which at first does
seem a little bit strange. We also thought that we didn't know
how this was all connected. It's a very interesting
story if you want to read in the paper, but I'm just going to use this slide
to
connect them. So we found that focal deletion
in chromosome 9p21
was leading to the instability of this SKI
complex. It's called super killer complex.
And microsatellite instability was causing mutations in
TTC37, and TTC37 was also part
of this SKI complex, and mutations would cause this complex to
be not functional and degraded.
And then the SKI complex and Pelo as well, HBS1L, they both work to
release ribosomes during translation when those
get stuck during no go, no stop
issues. So if you don't have SKI
complex functional, now inhibit Pelo, the cells get pushed
further, and they die.
But beyond all these discoveries and specific
examples, and these are the ones that are closer to me, but there are many
others, interesting ones in the literature using DEMAP
data. But beyond that,
I think what we're really proud of is how DEMAP
has democratized discovery. So with the DEMAP
portal, we have more than 11,000 users per week, and we
have visits from around the country.
And so
releasing this data into the portal has allowed labs, whether
they have
funding or they are more restricted,
and whether they have computational expertise or not, to be
enabled to use the data to make their discoveries.
And
since 2018, as I mentioned, we do scheduled releases.
We had done 26 so far, and these releases
are independent of publication. But early
on, we decided that we were not going to link data releases to
publication. This is because publications take a very long
time, and we all know. So we wanted to release the
data as we were generating the data.
So every release, we've been releasing the data that we
had available at that time so that the community will have the data
available rather than waiting a few years for the manuscript.
And also, there's a lot of impact that can be measured
that also makes us very proud. All the academic labs that
use the data on a regular basis in their lab to check on
something they are working on. At a conference, we often see
screenshots of the DEMAP portal. Last year, I saw many of those
at ACR. We'll see this year. And the
people in the pipeline meaning that are using Prism data to make
decisions. And we have also seen Prism and
DEMAP data being used in IND filings.
So this really shows that it can be really...
It's hard to put a number here, but it does really show that
DEMAP has been very impactful.
But the map is not finished. We still have a lot of work to do.
So we set up
to fill a few gaps. This is more recent work.
One of the gaps we wanted to fill was to
expand the number of models that we had in DEMAP,
because there were many tumor types as such that were still
underrepresented.
So a number of years ago, Jesse Bohm and Muni Singh
started the Cancer Cell Line Factory with the goal of
generating models, and in particular for models that we didn't
have any, or they were significantly
underrepresented.So they did this, and they generated
hundreds of models, including organoids, rare cancers, pediatric
cancers, and neurospheres, and others.
So we then wanted to integrate this data into
our existing data,
and we had to develop methods. So James Swander
and Lisa Brennan in my group, they worked
to make screening at genome scale, all these
next-generation models that were growing in 3D organoids
and spheroids possible. And we generated a data
set of more than 150 models. And importantly, we were
able to incorporate that data together with all our
existing data so that they can be explored in the portal.
So soon, you will go to the portal, and you will be able to see dependencies,
both in organoids and cell lines. Say, for the
majority of dependencies, they do not change.
We see the value of the organoids and the neurospheres.
These new generation models help us expand the
genomics and the transcriptional states that were not
represented in Demap before. That being said, there
are some interesting differences.
For instance, the one I'm showing here is two integrins,
ITGAV and ITGV1.
The dependency of those two is different.
Organoids are only dependent on ITGV1, but not in ITGAV.
Cell lines are mostly dependent on ITGAV, a little bit on
ITGV1. So we wouldn't know this until we have these
two types of models.
Now, another gap that we set out to fill was Demap,
we have focused mostly on single gene knockout and
single drug sensitivity. But we know to
amass some of the dependencies, we will need to use more than one gene to
suppress more than one gene or maybe use drug and genes or drug/drug.
So we started by focusing on paralogs.
Paralogs are a class that they have a
lot of redundancy, right? Because they are paralogs, and they are
most likely than others to be masked.
So Bill Sellers' group created a library of more
than 27,000 paralog
pairs, and we screened close to 300 models.
And what we found is that, yes, some dependencies might be
the same whether you suppress one gene or both, but some of them
are very different. So in this example, I'm showing
AKT1 versus AKT1 and 2.
And you can see how there's
a lot of cell lines, the dependency is correlated. It doesn't matter.
So you see most of the cell lines are dependent on
AKT1, for the most part. But then there are a
subset of cell lines that you can only see dependency if
you knock out both AKT1 and AKT2. This is what I'm
highlighting here in this box.
So for seeing this dependency, you have to knock out both.
So this obviously has implications for anyone working on
targeting paralog genes, whether it is better to have a more
specific, less specific, and maybe biomarkers
for that.
So finally, the last gap I'm going to talk about here is the
expansion of biomarkers. We expanded biomarkers
both by generating new data and building new computational features.
Biomarkers are key, not only for finding biomarkers for drug sensitivity,
but also for finding this linkage between
molecular alterations and gene dependencies to identify new targets.
So we did this, and for the past few years, we have continued to
expand. We now have chromatin accessibility data for
500 cell lines using ATAC-seq. We have transcript
isoforms using long-read RNA. We have all
proteomics, and we have many features, like an
apality and others,
that we have now in the portal. Many of
those were done in collaboration with other groups, but we
have brought them into the portal so they can be easily explored as the
data grows. This is the work of Katharina Campbell,
together with Sonia Iyer and her group on the computational side,
and Christy Winan in my group on the wet lab side.
Now in my last slide before I turn it to
Bill,
we are not done. We still want to expand.
And we'll continue to expand. There is a lot of work to be done, so there's a
few things that we are starting to do.
One is to model resistance systematically.
As we know, resistance is pervasive, and
there are no models of resistance.
We can't get models of resistance from patient
tumors systematically because those will be very hard.
So we are engineering the resistance, whether it's with
CRISPR engineering or with
using drug-adapted cell lines. We're also moving
beyond not only doing cell viability as a
readout to doing high dimensional profiling, because we
know that obviously viability is a very important phenotype for
cancer, but there are other phenotypes that are also equally important that
might not be read through viability.
So by using these high dimensional phenotypes, we can identify
those. This will generate a lot of dataAnd we'll use
AI-like approaches to
explore it. We're also expanding the data to
inform new therapeutics such as ADCs, CAR Ts,
and finally, we're developing the next generation of DepMap
portal in the AI era. We're starting to build an NCP
server that can talk to AI tools.
And Bill is going to provide his perspective and expand a little
bit on this, so I'm going to stop
here. But before I turn it to Bill, I just want to show
this picture because here I highlighted key people,
visionaries, and leaders, and key people along the
way. However, there's a huge number of people that have
supported and built DepMap. This is the current team, so many others
that have worked on this in the past.
So I want to take a moment to thank them all, their
talent and enthusiasm, and they showing up every day,
working through all the challenges, which there were many,
and making this possible. So,
I didn't have time to highlight everybody, but please remember
that when you go to the DepMap portal, this team is behind it.
And now I'll turn it to Bill, and then Bill and I will take
questions after his presentation. Thank you very much.
Yeah, I think I just want to echo what Paquita said about the sort of shoulders of
people and giants like Bill and Levi and Dave sitting here in the
front row that this was all built on.
It's really been an amazing time to watch
the evolution of this project. So one thing, these are
my disclosures.
These are the people who are currently running the project.
I do want to note that the DepMap
project is built
on the DepMap Consortium. So, I think sometimes
industry gets a bad rap for not supporting research.
None of this would exist at all without the support of
these industry funders. So I think that's really
important to keep in mind, and they do it knowing that
within a period of time, all the data are going to be released publicly.
So I just want to acknowledge the industry collaborators here who have
really made all of this possible, along with the team that
Paquita highlighted.
So, yeah, sometimes I think people think we're all done. We did it.
Single gene knockout. Every gene's been knocked out in 1,000 cell lines.
What more could there be to do?
And when are we going to get there? In the famous words of Monsieur
Incroyable, "We get there when we get there."
So, no, we are not there yet. We haven't solved cancer.
Cancer still needs a lot of work before we get to curative therapies.
And some of the questions that remain, Paquita has started to highlight.
One of the ones we're very interested in is, do genetic
redundancies mask druggable dependencies?
Or even more broadly, what are the combination dependencies across
all cancer? Because if we're going to get to curative therapy, we know single
gene knockouts and
single gene targeting therapeutics are not going to be sufficient.
So as Paquita mentioned, we've been working on knocking
out, as the first foray into combination space, a very narrow
part of the combination space, which is
comprised of near neighbor paralogs.
So think of MEK1, MEK2. We can make inhibitors of MEK1, MEK2, but
when we do a CRISPR screen, we don't mimic the inhibitor because we're targeting
either MEK1 or MEK2. So this is a data set
that has now been generated in 282 cancer cell lines.
One very small vignette that I find interesting is if we
look at FGFR altered cancers, that means FGFR2
and 3 primarily, we see that they are dependent on
NRAS and KRAS co-depletion, but you can see they are
completely independent of single knockouts of KRAS
or NRAS, and they are equally dependent on
KRAS and NRAS as KRAS mutant cells are dependent on KRAS
itself. So this is a very strong dependency and
completely fitting with the role of FGF signaling through
FRS2, two RAS isoforms. So
obviously, with the birth of pan RAS inhibitors, this gives us
the opportunity to immediately go from this observation to
whether or not
this would be therapeutically relevant.
And so taking an FGFR-driven gastric cancer,
SNU16, we can compare an FGFR2 selective
inhibitor, a pan RAS inhibitor, and the combination and show that
there is improved efficacy with the combination of a pan RAS and
FGFR inhibitor. So this is work that we're excited to see
potentially move to an IIT trial of some sort.
Okay, so that type of data is available inside our
portal, but hasn't been released yet on the public portal, but you should see
sometime this year a change on the portal where instead of
just going to CRISPR and then gene, you'll be able to
go to CRISPR and gene pair. And so for example, here's what I
just showed you, KRAS and NRAS, this is not the full data set, versus
KRAS. And you can see in red, most of the KRAS
tumors are primarily driven by a KRAS
dependency alone. We have this sort of
KRAS-NRAS mutant cell line that's highly dependent on NRAS.
In this data set, there aren't the FGFR-driven cell lines yet,
but sometime this year, you'll have access to this type of
data.Okay. So Pakita mentioned the problem
of therapeutic resistance, and this goes to the heart of what we're trying to do,
which is combination therapy to cure cancer.
And one of the problems with our current approaches is most of the time we're doing
short-term combination studies in small numbers of cells that
don't mimic the gigantic diversity of both cell
states and genetics that we face in a human being when we apply one
drug. So how can we decide what is the second drug to apply
when we don't know the escape mechanisms and short-term cultures and
synergy don't predict for the defeating a combination's
ability to defeat resistance? So we've decided one way to do that
is to look at resistance directly.
And that was motivated, at least in part, by an experiment Takahiro Ito
did in the lab, where
we were interested in finding paralog lethalities, and we had this
observation that DUSPs were lethal in the setting of
NRAS mutant tumors. At the same time, in Levi's lab,
BRAF-resistant lines had been generated and subjected to single
gene knockouts, and that gave them the ability to look at the
difference between the parental cell and the resistant cell.
And what was quite interesting is, as expected, they lost
dependence on downstream positive regulators in the BRAF
pathway, but they gained increasing dependence on
negative regulators of the pathway.
So it wasn't just that the resistance cells became
immune to RAF signaling. They gained new
susceptibilities. And Tak went on to show that, in fact, when you take
those cells and knock out either DUSP4 or DUSP6, there's not much
effect. The parental cells have a viability decrease with the double
knockout of DUSP4, 6, but the resistant cells are very
sensitive and more sensitive than the parental cells.
So this goes back, and I think this is from Levi's review maybe,
to the problem that we face when we're thinking about resistance, which is we
have what appear to be hundreds of different divergent
mechanisms of resistance. People have called this the whack-a-mole
problem that you would have to go around whacking each of these little moles.
But what if those whack-a-moles are actually all doing the same thing?
That is, in a given pathway, they're providing one solitary
function, which in this case might be the activation or
reactivation of ERK. And what if that conferred
new dependence on maintaining ERK at the right level?
So we've been exploring that by looking at whether or
not after you develop resistance to a BRAF
inhibitor, are you now increasingly sensitive to an
activator of ERK? And so here's the experiment where you take naive
cells, you either treat with an inhibitor or you activate ERK, and you can
see both of those events have negative consequences for cell
growth. But if you make them resistant and then you activate ERK,
you basically wipe out the remaining cell population.
And that's just illustrated here where you can do the experiment in either order
and you get the same result.
So that leads us to this question, can we study this now
more broadly across cancer? That is, are there convergent
mechanisms of function in the setting of resistance that
we might exploit therapeutically?
And there would be two ways to do that.
One is what we just saw was isogenic cell line pairs where you have a parental
and you have a resistant form. Now, generating them by treatment to resistance
is one way to do that. But given the emerging clinical data
where we now know from ctDNA the patterns of resistance in
patients, we could just engineer the cell lines to have the exact
resistant alleles already seen in patients.
So ResMAP, as Pakita described, its goal is to
discover or find or answer the question as to whether there are
convergent nodes in the resistance setting across different tumor types,
across different therapeutic modalities by engineering
isogenic, in this case,
quintuples of the different resistant alleles, and
maybe doing it in three sensitive cell lines at a time to get some idea of
reproducibility. And then all of these would be subjected
to CRISPR knockout screens looking for functional
convergence of the resistant mechanisms.
So, fortunately, we're collaborating with ATCC on this,
so they're helping to do some of the isogenic engineering.
But that also means there's a benefit to the community.
ATCC will be making those cell lines available in their
catalog.
Okay, so we're not ignoring drug-adapted cells, and so many
people in the community have reached out to us to provide
drug-adapted, drug-resistant cells that have been cultured to resistance.
Of course, we don't exactly know what the resistant
mechanisms are, but once we sequence them, either by whole genome
sequencing and RNA-seq, we'll presumably find out whether there's a
genetic or cell state change, and then again, use these
in CRISPR screens. And so this, led by Kirsty and
Florencia, is ongoing and will be the next
generation of DepMap-like data that you'll be
seeing in the future.
I just showed you this example of sort of hyperactivation, and it's sort of
an example of this notion that cells
that are oncogenically driven do not drive the oncogene pathway to its
maximal extent. In fact, they're living in a state of optimal
fitness where there's actually a balance between negative regulation, as
I showed you with DUSP4, 6, and positive activation, either through
BRAF and ERK, and you can actually get viability effects
in both directions.
This is interesting to me because I can't imagine how the cell figures out a
singular mechanism of resistance that deals with the switch from one
of these states to the other, and while risky, makes
me think that we should more... systematically probe
for hyperactivation lethalities as well.
So we're trying to ask that question.
We don't have a screening mechanism yet in place to do that.
CRISPRa would be obviously one possibility, though I think it
probably needs still some technical development.
Okay, so most of what Pakita has talked about and most of what I've just talked
about has to do with the left side of this therapeutic
binary graph, which is cell intrinsic targets.
But obviously, we're making a lot of progress in the field in
targeting cell extrinsic or surface targets.
And initially, one might think cell lines might not be that useful for this,
but I think in the end, when you make a therapeutic, usually someone's going to put
it on a cell line. So maybe it will be helpful to people generating
biotherapeutics to know more about the surface and surface
proteome in
these cell lines. So Muni's group, which you heard was the
CCLF, along with Eric Fisher and Catherine Donovan at the
Dana-Farber, have been conducting with support from Stand Up to
Cancer and Bayer Pharmaceuticals, surface enrichment mass spec
proteomics. It took a little while to get this right, but you can see
in orange things that are annotated as surface proteins,
substantially enriching in the biotinylated surface
enrichment over the whole proteomics, which is shown on the
x-axis. So we've completed 100 surface enrichment mass
specs with the goal of completing another 100.
Then we have to take a breath to see if we have enough money, see if we have enough
money
to keep going. But at least at first, we are seeing that we're
discovering previously unannotated proteins that
look like, for all purposes, they are in fact on the surface,
though they weren't previously known to be.
So one possibility is after 200 cell lines, we'll find out we're not discovering
any more new surface proteins, and then we may not need to
keep going. But this is a new direction that's underway.
Another cool thing that's happening in the world of proteomics, and
if you're a mass spec person, you might want to take careful note of this, is the
migration away from mass spec towards
specific affinity reagents that enrich
for binding to specific proteins.
So when I grew up, I had to do Northern blots to look at RNA.
I had to do Southern blots to look at DNA. Then we had qPCR.
Now, RNA-Seq is $60. Okay, so when
protein analysis becomes a next-gen sequencing assay,
that's going to be exciting for all of us.
And so we're very hopeful that that might be the case, and we're
exploring two different emerging technologies.
One, Olink, which is two different antibodies targeting the same
protein for specificity. You can see we've now run
475 cell lines. Olink provided a substantial
free pilot experiment in this regard.
But really excitingly, 1,485 proteins in the
Olink panel are not detected by either of the
proteomic data sets that are currently in DepMap, and the Sanger data
set was a DIA data set.
So I think we're clearly missing a lot in the mass spec
that's being picked up by an affinity-based mechanism.
It's not without its issues. When you saturate with two different
antibodies, you can get a hook effect.
So there are some
downsides there.
And then SomaLogic uses RNA aptamers to
detect binding, first on arrays, and now they're
interested in converting to a sequencing-based assay.
Their panel supposedly detects 11,000 proteins, and we're
embarking on a pilot with them. So we're very hopeful
that these new emerging technologies, which I think will only get
more broad in their ability to detect different proteins, will
increase over time and may become the next generation of
proteomics for the DepMap project.
Okay, so Pakita also mentioned this, but we have all this data, but the
most important question is: how does therapeutic efficacy align
with either genetic vulnerability or any other feature on these data
sets? And there's sort of a second question, which I think I'll show you some
data that suggests to me the prism assay might be quite good at this.
Do we have a good enough inhibitor or even better, do we have the
optimal inhibitor for a given target that we're interested
in? So you heard about the prism assay.
We're in the middle of getting close to submitting a paper on something called the
OncRef data set, led by Matt Reese, as you heard, Matt Emmett,
Mustafa, and Jen.
This covers 900 bar-coded cell lines with 265
small molecules. We tried to scrape every newest generation
molecule just going into phase one that people would be interested in.
And I'll give you one small vignette that shows maybe what the
power of this can look like. Going back to a
synthetic lethality that Pakita mentioned, which is the synthetic
lethality of deleting MTAP and becoming sensitive to
PRMT5 depletion. So we showed that it's not just
PRMT5 depletion that you need to achieve.
You need to form a very specific type of
molecule, which is cooperative with the excess level of
MTA that accumulates in these cells.
So a generation of inhibitors is being generated called
MTA cooperative PRMT5 inhibitors that is
superseding the earlier generation of SAM cooperative.
Now, the reason for that is you can see if you take a SAM cooperative inhibitor and
run it in prism, it has a very broad
quasi-pan-lethal phenotype, not quite as pan-lethal as
paclitaxel or a WEE1 inhibitor,
adevasertib. But of course, compared to
highly selective targeted inhibitors like ABL inhibitors, this is the
allosteric ABL inhibitor or a highly selective BRAF
inhibitorThe SAM cooperative inhibitor is quite broadly
acting. If we look at three different PRMT5
inhibitors, two of which were in the clinic,
you can see greater and greater specificity compared to the SAM
cooperative, though the first generation TANGO compound, you can almost see
this double
peak suggesting it had both SAM and MTA cooperative
inhibition. And for the Mirati compound, we had two compounds,
1719, which was the clinical compound, and 9768, which
is a tool compound. But you can see 9768 has a
better profile than 1719. Presumably, there had to be
trade-offs made on pharmacology and PK and oral absorption,
but it means a better PRMT5/MTA cooperative
inhibitor is achievable somewhere, somehow.
So I think this is quite interesting.
TNG908 was superseded by the next TANGO drug, so it stopped in the
clinic, and maybe this could have been predicted by sort of the profile you
see here.
I'll just skip that.
So the next most important question that everybody's fearing about is will
AI eliminate
all of our jobs? And by disclosure, my son now works at OpenAI, so
he's actively working to eliminate my job.
So,
we're not going to answer that question, but we are well aware
of the power that AI might have to make
either insights into the data or just make the data
available to people like me who aren't computational biologists and
can't spend all day trying to figure out how to make the graphs that I want to
make. So, the Cancer Data Science Group has
been working, as you heard, to make an AI-enabled
ChatGPT-like interface for the DepMap with the idea
that sometime by the end of this year, we'll have a prototype
portal that's AI-enabled. And so here's an example Lauren
Golden in the Cancer Data Science Group gave me, where she
queried KRAS mutant lung
adenocarcinoma, and then we're
work based on Claude.
It goes into our data, finds all the things it can generate, and
then in this case, ranks the top synthetic lethal gene candidates for
KRAS, which is KRAS itself. Not surprising, but I think this is
quite good because it didn't hallucinate some new synthetic lethality.
It basically didn't find one. And we don't have a
downstream single gene synthetic lethal with KRAS.
But this is an example, and you can imagine the power of something like
this to allow people, maybe clinicians would get better access to the
data, hopefully not the marketing people.
But this is our goal, is to make the portal just
like a Gemini-type interface.
Okay, so I don't think AI is going to eliminate our jobs because we still need
a lot of data. You can't build these models without data, and the
reality is our datasets are small compared to
the vast problem of cancer. So I think we still have quite a ways to go
in terms of generating the data. So hopefully, we will not be out of a job
anytime soon.
All right. So I just wanted to end and thank again all of you for coming.
Thank AACR for recognizing all the great work that everybody
who has contributed to the DepMap team have done, and as I mentioned, all the
people who have helped fund and stimulate this amazing project.
Thank you very much, and we're happy to take questions.
Do
we have any questions?
So,
right. So, Alan D'Andrea, I'm just so impressed.
These talks are fantastic. It's wonderful you won
the team award. It makes perfect sense.
Just
one comment, I guess, when I think about combination therapy, point number
one that Bill was just making.
I was thinking about drug resistance, and sometimes you find situations where you
have two drugs that don't work
synergy when given in combination, but in fact, the sequential delivery of those
drugs matters a lot.
And one sequential delivery might be antagonistic, and the
other sequential might be
growth inhibitory. So just sort of comment on the first
point that you were making, Bill, and whether or not your system could take that
into account in a particular way.
First, I totally agree with you. I think, in fact, even combinations that work
together at the same time, if they're
creating a bottleneck, if one of them is
primarily a bottleneck and the second is blocking resistance, it
might not be necessary to give them at the same time as long as you gave them in
cycle quickly enough.
Right.
If you don't allow escape, you wouldn't have to give them simultaneously,
and I think toxicity would be way lower.
Right.
So I think your point is really good.
I don't think we've thought of a CRISPR DepMap-like
way to do that.
Yeah.
No, I think that's good. I'm glad you answered that way.
Simultaneous delivery might be quite important in one setting because if
you give it slowly over time, you give the first one, you might get an acquired
vulnerability or an acquired resistance that makes the second
drug not work. So...
Right. The only reason I'm saying you might still get away with sequential is
there's still a time-dependent nature of that emergent resistant phenotype.
Fair enough.
Yeah.
Thanks.
All right.
Bill, on this side.
So a question regarding the data that you showed about
the integrins showing the differential effects, right?
So I think
a broader conceptual idea would be that again-organoid setting, you're
probably looking at different biological entities, but a different
way to think about it could be that what you're growing the cells
in,
we are feeding them different things, then we are reading out different
dependencies. So, as more and more evidence
becomes available about the nutritional
state, the metabolic state of the tumor cell, should the DepMap
start thinking about answering dependencies for
the different lineages in the context of their metabolic states,
or think of that?
Yeah. It is a very good point. And organoids and cell lines have very
different media. Most of the cell lines are grown in serum, and
organoids are grown in specific media without serum.
And certainly, we have seen that that causes-- In fact,
that's probably the majority of differences that you're seeing.
The one I show is mostly related to the cells growing on
matrigel versus not. But the way we think about it
is,
what we're doing is we're representing different cell states, different
metabolic states, by using organoids.
So when you see the differences, yeah, you don't necessarily would think
like, this is because it's an organoid cell line.
You have to think that this is because they are
in a different state. And hopefully, once we have the data in the portal,
some of these things could be untangled.
Yeah, I was just going to say, I am not convinced that you can really study a lot
of metabolism in cell culture, and we would prefer to do those types
of CRISPR experiments in vivo. Yeah.
The challenge is, I think the
number of genes you can probably profile at one go in
vivo though, right?
Yeah, but like in the metabolic space, you probably could cover the metabolic
pathways. The problem in vitro, even when people say they're using human
plasma-like media, the problem is it's not being replenished every minute.
Your liver is maintaining homeostasis at a level that's
not maintained in cell culture. So I think it's extremely difficult to
mimic whatever is going on in vivo in a in vitro
setting. Yeah.
Hey, Bill. I just had one question.
You mentioned isogenic cells as a way to model those.
Have you done any systematic evaluation of the generation of
in vitro isogenic models versus
what's happening in the body, in terms of the order of operations and how
that affects those models?
Not really, no. So what we're doing is let's say
many patients have been treated with BRAF
inhibitors, and then they're emerging with
KRAS mutation or NRAS mutation. Then we're basically saying,
let's take three sensitive BRAF mutant cells and
engineer in each of those a KRAS
resistance while they're in drug.
So of course, that has to be single clone for each of those lines, which
is itself problematic. So we're trying to isolate multiple
different clones, make sure they behave similarly, and potentially re-pool
them to maintain some
heterogeneity. I don't know if that's really-
And have you done any systematic sort of evaluation of what those look like in
a multi-omics fashion versus what's happening in the patient?
You can-- If you want to say.
Yeah.
This is a very good point. This is a reductionist approach.
But that being said, I think reductionist approach gets
a bad reputation, and one wants to model the whole complexity of
human cancer. But what that does is it allow us to identify
links, right? We can identify a direct link between that particular
alteration and a dependency, for instance.
And yes, those have to be confirmed in vivo and kind of
combined with other things. But,
I think they do provide useful. And as Bill mentioned, we're
doing it in three different cell lines at least, or maybe
four. So
if what we find is consistent, then that's good.
If what we find is not consistent across the four, that means we might need more.
But it is a very good point, Glenn.
Yeah, you'll be amused to know that we've already seen
clones come out with different cell states with the same isogenic mutation.
On one hand, that's a great opportunity.
On the other hand, now we have to pay for two screens instead of one.
Yeah. Over here.
It's nice that you're expanding into organoids, but I was wondering whether it
would also make sense to expand the 2D cell line space,
because the number 1,000 is arbitrary, and the
question is what type of information content you could
unleash by going from 1,000 to 10,000, and/or
by sort of repairing the gaps within that
cell line space. So I think that the 2D cell line space is something to look at,
and that it would be nice also with current day
technology to actively expand that space.
I'm so happy that you say this, and Bill is laughing.
I think he's happy for the same reason.
Yeah, cell lines are great tools.
The reason for the starting to screen in organoids is not because
necessarily we think they are better than cell line.
In fact, I don't think they are better.
They are just different, and they model different aspect of metabolism
and growth, et cetera. But in the recent year,
in the past five, six years,
the models that have been generated have mostly been organoids, particularly
for epithelial cancers, because it's much easier to
derive models through this approach.
And cell lines is very difficult to derive models.
And we have run out of models. We have the whole catalog of
any potential commercial bank that you can think of.
And thanks to many, many generous collaborators.
If anyone is here, thank you for being generous and they're
sharing lines. We're still, like, for anyone that has
cell lines of value, we could get them, but I don't think
we have sufficient.
Sometimes I wonder, Jas, how many cell lines are just trapped in
academic labs and not available. And that's kind of depressing to me
that people would hold onto them.
Yeah, I don't know for what. For some licensing
fee.One
thing that's interesting is Mooney's group has been using these, like what I have,
some peristaltic pump kind of thing to take the organoids
and grow them as 2D cells.
And we've been able to transition in gastric cancer some 70
organoids to 70 2D lines that then can
grow either as organoids or 2D lines.
So that is kind of hopeful to me to convert many of the organoids
into a screenable model.
As you probably know, like the funding for cell generation is pretty
much zero. So that's also been tough.
Thank you for the excellent
work and sharing with us. So I have two questions.
Number one, are you considering to include more immunology-related
features like antigen presentation, response to T cell
mediated killing? And the second question, officially is DeepMap
or DepMap? Thank you.
The first one was about immuno-oncology?
Yeah. Immunology-related characters like antigen presentation,
response to T cell mediated killing.
So antigen presentation, I think would be extremely difficult to do across
1,000 cell lines. Like, yeah, MHC proteomics, that would
be hard or expensive or both.
In terms of T cell killing, the prism
assay has been used to do cell
killing with NK cells. We're doing it also
with different T cell populations.
I don't know, Jen, has the CAR T been done in the prism assay?
No, but so the prism assay with 900 bar-coded cell lines, there
we can do in a custom format, a
T cell or other cellular killing assays.
And so it's not the easiest thing to do, but we are doing those.
Yeah, and I may add, so for doing antigen
presentation, Bill said that would be very difficult and that would be one
phenotype to test among many others.
So this is why the high dimensional phenotypes that could,
not directly but indirectly, identify those genes.
That's where we're going. So,
not directly
testing this, but through those
high dimensional phenotypes you will be able to infer if a gene does
affect antigen presentation.
Thank you. And it's DeepMap or DepMap?
Thank you.
Dep.
Hi. So when you guys started this, I think many of us
thought the integration of chemical biology and genomics and
genetics was going to be fantastic, and it is great,
but it seems like even with the sophisticated molecular
tools
on the chemical side, we're basically doing GI 50s and cell growth inhibition.
So is there a roadmap going forward to really treat the compounds as their
own special children?
So there have been some, I would say industry sponsored
specific collaborations where thousands of compounds have
been profiled against the 900 prism
encoded cell lines. So people have been interested, if that's what you're referring
to, like chemo genomics.
It is, but again, that's cell growth inhibition.
There's no gene signatures. There's no apoptotic
indexes. There's no differentiation.
Yes. So as Paquita sort of has been referring to, we are working
on getting to perturb seek-like levels.
I would say
we go back and forth a little bit on this.
The cost needs to come down still to make that practical.
The way I look at DepMap is, it's a project that needs to be done
at scale, otherwise a lab can do
one compound, 10 compounds. So we look for the
opportunity when the cost reaches a point where we can scale something and
answer a big question like you're talking about, and I'm not
sure perturb seek is there yet. I don't know if you probably want to say something
on that.
We can talk later.
Everybody's promising me the 0.0001 penny a
perturbation price someday.
I have one more question. So sort of regarding the
problem of someday not having to play Whac-A-Mole,
can you comment on why it is that you haven't attempted to
extend the duration of drug treatment to two weeks, three weeks, four weeks
rather than use cell lines that have already developed genetic resistance?
There's this sort of intermediate persister phase, which I know it's technically
more difficult to
replace.
No, I can definitely answer this question.
So
if you wanted to mirror what's happening in a human being, so in a
human being, when we start treatment in a metastatic patient, there's something
like 10 to the 10th cells already present.
You don't see mutations at that point because you can't see them.
That doesn't mean they're not there, right?
So my feeling is most of the time you see emergent resistant, there's some
population that has already existed, that comes out.
So when we're seeing it in humans four weeks later or six weeks later, it's
because of the scale of the tumor that's already present when we start to
treat. If we go to cell culture,
even if we did treat for four weeks, if we're doing 500 cells or
1,000 or 20,000, the genetic diversity or cell state
diversity isn't represented.
So to get to the representation, we're taking this human data, the
mutations we see in human, and engineering them back into the cells.
That's our solution to the problem of insufficient
heterogeneity in the common experimental setups.
But I think that's based on the assumption that-
... acquired resistance is driven purely by preexisting mutant cells, right?
It's
driven by the assumption that at least in some cases that's the case.
Mm-hmm.
Which means if you don't set up your systems to mimic that, you won't see
it.
Mm-hmm.
So we're not immune to the idea that cell state would be important.
And we are in fact trying to engineer cell states
so we can get isogenic cells that are epithelial or mesenchymal,
for example, SOX9 high, SOX10 high, for
example.
But in some cases, we're seeing that pop out anyway.
Mm-hmm.
Thank you.
I'll just say one other risk on the shorter term things that you tend to see when
the... This happened actually many years ago with Gleevec.
So Gleevec came along, people had K562 cells as the only B-cell variable
positive cell. They treated it to resistance, and they got transporter
upregulation. Partly because that cell has almost
no mutations and doesn't reflect the actual B-variable mutations.
You switch to a different cell line, you get all the mutations that were
seen in the clinic. So I think this is the risk of not having a
heterogeneous population. In that case, you got a
resistance mechanism that never occurred in humans.
This is more of a comment and forward-looking question.
I'm thrilled to see the dependency map.
Having been at the Broad when it was starting out, it is so cool to see everything
that's happened and hear everybody talk about it.
One thing you said in the what's left to do or AI
is different phenotypes. Do you ever see the dependency
map moving beyond the cancer dependency map with
different phenotypes, or is that too far in the future, and the
only, back to your point, Bill, about cost, cell
viability being the one phenotype that you can really robustly and
cheaply
look at?
So with thin cancer, I do see a path to
having other phenotypes.
I don't think we're thinking on a path to moving beyond cancer, but
these high dimensional, like in particularly perturb-seq-like approaches,
would provide us information about what are the targets doing
beyond cell viability. So this is the...
We're not thinking about a specific phenotype because, again, you will have to pick
some, and beyond, say, viability, I know which one is broad
enough for us to go into that one in particular, but with
perturb-seq-like approaches, we just have to make them
scalable enough.
Yeah.
Yeah. So the Broad has a more general interest in perturb-seq across
non-oncology indications. I don't think anybody's called it DepMap
yet.
The one in cancer that we get a lot of questions about is normal cells and the
effect of knocking out a gene or the drug effect.
And as you know, they're like, the problem is those normal cells still have
to grow, and then they're not really normal.
So we've had a lot of problems thinking about how
to do, quote, "normal cell toxicity in
vitro."
Hi. I was wondering if, in your paralog work,
if you were interested in looking at even higher order paralog
families and looking towards the future of knocking out three or
four at a time?
Not me personally. I think I'm too old to think about that.
But, I think the problem is we can't even do two gene knockouts at
scale.
Okay.
The total number of two gene knockouts, I think it's 400 million that would have to
be queried to do all possible pairwise
combinations. And
when we do these screens, we're not just doing the
pairs, we're doing the singles all over again with a
cutting control. So that means we have to do all the singles and all the doubles.
Now, imagine we had to do a triple knockout.
The right way to do that is all the singles, all the doubles, and all the triples,
all in the same library. And you can't just say we want to do that with one
guide per gene. So you end up being down to
a very, very small library of genes that you
can target. And going back to what I was saying about scalability,
then it becomes like a pet project of which triple knockouts do
you really want to do. So for that reason, we're not doing a lot of
that.
I think, John Dench has developed new libraries that go to three
and four. So I think there's certainly methods available
to do that.
Yeah, I was wondering if the informer platform was maybe going to expand into
DepMap or-
It's not that it doesn't work, it's more that,
yeah, I'm trying to figure out how do you make it something other...
Almost in all the combination space, you're basically picking
genes you're in love with. Like, "Oh, I want to study this gene set," or, "I
want to do epigenetics," or, "I want to do this." So yeah, it's a
little hard to figure out the whole strategy around combinations in general.
Thank you.
Question.
First, just want to say this is so well deserved, and
just kudos to the entire team that conceived, built, and has implemented
this project because the impact has been phenomenal.
And I think beyond what's been talked about here in therapeutic space, the
mechanism that one can learn about genetic
mutations and what constitutes a vulnerability then is really
illuminating. Question is, and what we're really trying to
understand are what are the cell
intrinsic defects that might constitute targets in
human cancer? And it's been touched on here is cell lines, how well do
they represent that? Do you have any
estimation of the sensitivity specificity of what we're finding?
In other words, for a type of cancer that's well-represented in
DepMapAre the cell lines revealing almost all the
vulnerabilities that we want to know about?
90% of them there, but if you go in vivo, you'll pick up a couple more,
versus we're just scratching the surface, and in vivo,
as Bill was talking about, all sorts of different metabolic considerations.
So any early estimates of sensitivity, specificity in
well-represented cancers?
For sure there are differences in metabolic dependencies
in vivo versus in vitro, but I don't think there are a lot of
differences. If you do a screen in kind of a xenograft model,
there are not a lot of differences. That's what we have seen.
It's not zero, so you found some. So I don't think doing a screen in vivo is
going to be a treasure trove. That being said, those screens are also
done in immunocompromised mice, so I think what we're missing is the immune
system. That's clearly... And some of the microenvironment.
So there, all of those vulnerabilities, those are the
ones that we're not finding with cell lines.
But I
think from cell intrinsic, as
long as we have the genetic alterations that, those
vulnerabilities and the cell stage,
I think we're finding a lot of them.
This is the last question, then we're going to close the session.
All right. Thank you. Very phenomenal work and kudos to the
team.
My question goes to Dr. Vazquez.
When you were speaking, you spoke about
the high throughput assay that you developed
with the bar-coded different cell lines.
I wanted to find out, was that a co-culture of these different cell
lines? And how did they look thriving together?
Yeah, that's the prism assay, so Jen Roth here would be
better to answer that question. But yeah, those different cell lines that have
the barcode, and they are co-cultured together.
They are pool of 25 at the same time.
And then you do many pools of 25 to get to the
900 cell lines. So 25 cell line. And yes, it's
possible, and we get this question a lot that the co-cultures
could interfere, right? Because you have cell lines that might secrete something or
another. But I think for the most part, we don't see huge differences in
individual versus pooling.
Yeah, and actually the co-culture effect, the bias you might get is
mitigated a little bit by having 25.
When you go down to smaller numbers, it could become worse, where one cell line can
dominate the other four, for example.
I would like to thank and congratulate again the team at DIP
Map. I think that's my accent, calling it the DIP Map.
This is real an accent problem.
And the way, that's from my heritage is Moroccan and French, that's why.
And thank you and congratulations, and thank you for all people that did come
here for the questions and the interaction. Thank you.
Yes, we want to thank too